[Music]
Ally
Sean oh my God what are you doing here
you know why I'm just visiting my old
haunts on the off chance I might run
into an X from 10 years ago how many of
you running two so far
[Music]
let's go think about what would happen
if you hadn't left all those years ago
I've been kind of wondering the same
thing recently
if maybe I made the wrong
I haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
play Jojo
hey what a wonderful thing for us all to
be here so thank you to the bride and
groom for giving us a reason to
celebrate to Sean and Cassidy
yeah
yeah
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
I mean you can just call him Sean
hi you're still here if my being here is
making you uncomfortable no no it
wouldn't be very cool of me to kick out
one of Sean's honest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
she actually reminds me a lot of me at
that age
or he like a nudist I was I have an idea
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley pit
Campbell do not taste the naked ladies
this has gone way too far I don't know I
don't know what to do anymore
[Music]